مؤلم ومفجع منظر انتشار جثث عندما تدفن
تحت الانقاض او تتناثر فوقها او تطفو على
الماء في الكوارث الطبيعيه او النزاعات
المسلحه ويدفع ذلك عاده الناس الى دفنها
بشكل متسرع كما هو الحال في المقابر
الجماعيه في محاوله لتخطي الفاجعه وقد
يكون سبب ذلك الخوف من ان تشكل هذه الجثث
تهديدا صحيا لكن اين تكمن الحقيقه هي
مقاربه قد تكون ضاره بالسكان يقول كل من
الاتحاد الدولي لجمعيه الصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر ولجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر ومنظمه الصحه العالميه فدفن جثث
الموتى بسرعه وسوء اداره يعرض السلطات
والمجتمعات المحليه لضغوطات نفسيه هائله
ومشاكل اجتماعيه وقانونيه لاهالي الضحايا
فالاصل ان تشمل عمليه الدفن المدار بشكل
جيد مقابر فرديه يمكن تتبعها بسهوله
وتوثيقها بشكل صحيح وان يضمن ذلك ان يكون
معروفا الموقع الدقيق لك والمعلومه
المرتبطه بها وممتلكاتها الشخصيه كقاعده
عامه تقول ذات المنظمات ان رفات ضحايا
الكوارث الطبيعيه لا يتسبب في اوبئه لان
الناس يموتون نتيجه اصابتهم بجروح او غرقا
او نتيجه حروق وبالتالي لا يكونون عاده
حاملين لجراثيم من المحتمل ان تسبب
الاوبئه فالجثه لا تشكل سوى خطر صحي ضئيل
لكن اين يكمن الاستثناء الحاله الوحيده
التي تشكل فيها جثث الموتى خطرا للاصابه
بالاوبئه هي عندما تكون الوفيات ناجمه عن
بعض الامراض المعديه او عند حدوث كارثه
طبيعيه في منطقه تنتشر فيها هذه الامراض
اذ يمكن ان تؤدي الجثث الموجوده في المياه
او بالقرب منها الى مخاوف الصحيه جراء
الافرازات وتلوث مصادر المياه مما يؤدي
الى خطر الاصابه بالامراض وتوضح المتحدثه
باسم منظمه الصحه العالميه ان الجثه ليست
السبب الرئيسي للخطر بل كل ما في الماء
مثل الطين والمواد الكيميائيه تصيب
بروتوكولات منظمه الصحه والاغات الدوليه
بعدم ترك الجثث بالقرب من مصادر مياه
الشرب وحمايه هذه المصادر وتطهير مياه
الشرب وهو امر كافي للوقايه من الامراض
المنقوله بالمياه ووفق تاكيد مختصين في
الاستجابه للطوارئ تاتي المخاطر الصحيه
اكثر من الناجين انفسهم الذين يمكن ان
ينشروا الامراض لهذا يحثون على عدم تسرع
في دفن الجثث جماعيا او حرقها فالاندفاع
غير الضروري للتخلص من جثث الموتى في
الكوارث او النزاعات لا يوفر وفق رايهم اي
فائده للصحه العامه
[موسيقى]